[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires
aujourd'hui en direct sur tv5 monde une
émission qui est réalisé avec vous le
savez ouest-france nice-matin france
antilles la montagne et 20 minutes qui
sont nos partenaires et puis mon invité
ce matin c'est chloé morin bonjour vous
êtes politologue bonjour aplomb et moira
vous avez créé un livre qui s'appelle on
a les politiques qu'on mérite c'est chez
fayard on le voit d'ailleurs
actuellement sur l'écran at on eu le
débat que l'on vérité je dirai oui sans
doute disons que à mon avis chacun aura
vu midi à sa porte dans ce débat les
partisans de marine le pen voyant à la
vente ou la proximité la capacité à
comprendre les gens elle a d'ailleurs
pas louper 1 1 une occasion de se
victimiser et de d'essayer de dépeindre
emmanuel macron comme technicien et
arrogant et l inverse les partisans d'
emmanuel macron vu quelqu'un qui
maîtrise ses sujets et qui est
extrêmement précis et sait faire c'est
montrer son expérience donc at elle été
mise en difficulté un moment donné
notamment sur l'emprunt russe on regarde
cet extrait
vous ne parlez pas à d'autres dirigeants
vous parlez à votre banquier quand vous
parlez de la russie mail macron parce
que il a accès à l'intégralité des
informations des services
français et puis vous êtes pertinemment
que ce qu'il dit est faux il sait
pertinemment que je suis une femme
absolument et totalement les bras
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de cet
extrait cet extrait tu étais très
intéressant parce que d'un côté il est
vrai que emmanuel macron là mais sans
doute en difficulté sur un point qui est
essentiel parce qu'il touche à la
souveraineté qu'elle est censée incarner
une femme libre c est l aile rexel
réplique et puis juste un peu plus loin
elle dit vous savez quand les français
vont emprunter de l'argent ils savent
que c'est pas c'est pas évident auquel
se elle ramène sa propre situation à la
situation des français notamment des
français modestes qui peut avoir avoir
des difficultés avec leur banque et donc
là encore en fait je pense que les
partisans des manuels macron y auront vu
une réplique qui faisait mouche et les
partisans de marine le pen sans doute se
seront seront restés solidaires derrière
elle chloé moins quand on emprunte de
l'argent à une banque on demande une
collatéral une caution mais emmanuel
macron ne lui a pas posé la question
qu'avez vous donner en collatéral en
caution pourquoi mais je pense qu'il
n'est pas allé au bout de sa critique
sans doute parce que parce que c'est
très technique
oui et puis que au fond c'est on rentre
dans un débat qui risque aussi de
commandes hier ou de là c'est tout le
monde parce qu'en fait tout le monde
sait qui a des rapports de force au
niveau international tout le monde sait
que comment dire qu'il ya une forme de
réelles politiques elle s'est imposée
aussi dans ce débat et elle a réussi à
être assez assez solide en fait même sur
cette critique vous le dire la
realpolitik s'est imposé dans ce débat
ah oui de fête oui dans un instant
reçoit stéphane bern et rédacteur en
chef de ouest france et directeur de la
rédaction de paris sur ce plateau
bonjour stéphane bern et merci d'être
avec nous bonjour beaucoup dormi cette
nuit j'en suis sûr dans un instant nous
avons interviewé chloé morin qui est
notre invité ce matin en face au
territoire aient les politologues et
vous la connaissez vous la voyez
beaucoup dans les médias 1 on va tout de
suite tu écoutais françois-xavier le
franc qui est en duplex depuis rennes
votre rédacteur en chef
bonjour qu'on aimera à ouest france nous
avons beaucoup aimé votre livre on a les
politiques qu'on mérite ça c'est le
titre du livre ce livre est très utile
il devrait d'ailleurs être lus par
toutes celles et ceux qui pensent que
les politiques sont tous pourris parce
que vous ne pensez précisant pas que les
politiques sont tous pourris vous nous
invitez à changer notre regard sur la
vie politique comment faire en sorte
demain d'organiser la participation
réelle active des citoyennes et des
citoyens à la vie politique parce qu'on
a l'impression aujourd'hui que trop
d'entre elles trop d'entre eux sont
spectateurs et non pas acteur
je pense qu'il ya pas de réponse toute
faite mais la première chose pour
apporter une réponse est de poser la
question et le le grand problème du
débat présidentiel c'est qu'on n'a pas
posé cette question là et que la
question démocratique d'ailleurs elle
est arrivée tout à la fin du début du
débat entre les deux
alors qu'elle est à mon avis première
est que je pense qu'on est capable de
dégager des compromis dans la société à
ces trans partisan sur justement la
nécessité de réengager les citoyens
transpartisane it et je vous ai entendus
au cours dudit liminaire sur le fait que
finalement si je comprends bien pour
vous hier je tout le monde a gagné on
est dans une espèce de match nul entre
mm macro et marine le pen du coup à quoi
ça sert ce genre de débat
pas c'est un exercice c'est un exercice
très convenue enfin je pense que
finalement ce qu'il faut interroger sur
tous et
c'est autant la politique que les médias
qui sont interrogés dans cette élection
parce que ce que l'on voit depuis
quelques depuis dix jours un peu plus
que la campagne du second tour a
commencé c'est que les intentions de
vote change un peu mais pas beaucoup
alors que les médias ont fait un travail
ont fait de manière quasi unanime un
travail de voile à de décortiquer le
programme de marine le pen et c'est donc
on voit bien qu'une partie des électeurs
ne sont plus perméables ni aux messages
des politiques ni aux messages des
médias lisse apparemment en est à quatre
jours du second tour à trois jours du
second tour il ya encore beaucoup
d'indécis quasiment un tiers des
électeurs se disent indécis on pourrait
imaginer qu'un grand débat comme celui
ci puisse permettra aux uns et aux unes
de changer d'avis avant avant le scrutin
c'est déjà arrivé à la dernière fois
marine le pen s'est humilié et sans
doute que ça a participé à amplifier la
victoire des là ce sera tous là pour
vous avez eu à plein débat auquel vous
moi je pense pas alors c'est vrai qu'il
va falloir regarder finement les pour ce
qui est des hésitants si ça fait
basculer certains mais je pense que
chacun a surtout consolider son propre
camp hier parce que chacun a joué sur
son propre terrain emmanuel macron sur
la compétence sur l'expérience marine le
pen sur leur ressenti la proximité et je
pense que du coup ces matches nuls en
quelque sorte parce que chacun s'est
adressé à son auditoire stéphane bern je
vous propose qu'on regarde un extrait
celui de la souveraineté claude morin ce
drapeau européen elle lui reproche
d'avoir
évidemment enlever le drapeau français
la voit remplacé par le drapeau européen
pour lancer la présidence de l'union
européenne c'était un moment fort en
l'écoutant on regarde pas mettez moi de
dire à emmanuel macron qu'il n'y a pas
souvent interpelle car il n'ya pas de
peuple européen j'ai bien compris vous
souhaitiez remplacer la souveraineté
française par la souveraineté européenne
vous en avez d'ailleurs vous l'avez fait
d'ailleurs symboliquement en remplaçant
le drapeau français sous l'arc de
triomphe par le drapeua rempli par le
drapeau européen
là c'est un moment où il marque un point
là c'est un moment où elle marque un
point parce que de fait même les plus
pro européen sont pas dans le sens ne
sont pas pour une dilution totale de la
france dans un grand tour européen en
pensez les peuples sont très différents
donc oui elle marque un point et alors
elle parvient quand même sur
l'intégralité du débat à ne pas trop
avoir l'air anti européenne parfois ils
donnent des gages y compris d'ailleurs
sur l'attitude de maquereau dans ce
débat qu'elle ait l'air pas trop anti
européenne elle voulait corriger cette
image et je pense qu'elle voulait
surtout pas faire peur donc parfois
d'ailleurs ça à la russie pour vous oui
parce que à certains moment même il
pouvait y avoir des commentaires sur
réseaux sociaux en dix ans elle se
défend pas assez je pense que c'était un
parti-pris elle voulait vraiment pas
avoir l'air agressive elle voulait avoir
l'air inoffensive entre guillemets et de
ce point de vue là enfin quitte du coup
a pas assez se défendre alors que
emmanuel macron porter des attaques
assez est rude donc je pense que de ce
point de vue là elle et elle y est
parvenu assez bien on sait que dans ce
genre d'exercice la commune ce qu'on
appelle la communication non verbale
pèse beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus que
ce que ce qui est dit réellement dans
les attitudes les intonations où les
petites phrases comme on commence que
vous le site huriez l'un et l'autre je
pense que emmanuel macron c'est moins
maîtrisé que
qu'anticipé parce qu'ils avaient des
attitudes qui parfois est et
condescendante à son égard il avait des
manières d'asséner certaines réponses ou
de remettre en cause son rôle du tombeau
et professeurs
2 voilà de dire ça c'est faux etc et
même la manière dont il se tenait
avec la race apprentis en plus par
moments on santé ddt voilà qui n'avait
pas finalement assez peu de respect pour
son adversaire et salement manifeste et
sur marine le pen envoyé en fait que l
été et fat surtout d'ailleurs au début
la première sa première tirade qui sur
le fond est très bonne parce qu'elle
part du peuple français ce qui est assez
assez malin on voit finalement quelques
elle tâtonne un peu calé qu'elle est
très tendue au fond et si c'est l'image
qu'elle aura renvoyé tout au long du
débat c'est finalement elle maîtrise
quand même pas autant ces sujets que lui
il ya une différence de niveau qui a ses
lois ses concernera public pendant cinq
ans oui oui bien sûr déjà il a dominé
techniquement et à 5 en mai mais là on
voit bien que à l'arrivée ont finalement
on est dans la même affiche que celle de
2017 président qui enfin un candidat qui
apparaît un peu arrogant ou voire
méprisants et une autre un peu hésitante
voire incompétente finalement les images
les images même s'il ya eu des efforts
et à un travail très fort des deux côtés
et l'expérience le les images ne sont
restées les mêmes oui même si je pense
vraiment que dans l'image que les
français avaient de marine le pen ya
cinq ans il y avait beaucoup plus cette
hargne cette dureté que qu'aujourd'hui
qui quitte quasiment gommer qu'elle a
réussi à gommer avec voilà toute sa
campagne depuis depuis septembre sur les
réseaux sociaux etc a beaucoup plus
souriante et mais beaucoup plus douce et
que emmanuel macron bains entre temps il
est devenu quand même le président de
toutes les petites phrases qui ont fait
qu'il était considéré comme méprisant et
arrogant stéphane bern et claude morin
qu'est notre invité la politologue ce
matin pour commenter ce débat d'hier
soir chenu qui est dessinateur
collaborateur bien connue de
ouest-france à une question à vous poser
sous forme de dessin et d'incitation au
vote en leur garde
bonjour ceux qui espéraient une
résurrection vie politique française à
pâques ont été déçus pas de surprise
dans les heures je veux dire dans les
urnes nous aurons donc le même face à
face qu'en 2017
enfin ça devient une habitude
tous les cinq ans vous avez vu le coq
emblème de la france est remplacé par un
castor car le mot d'ordre c'est faire
barrage mais si barrage il doit y avoir
et bien c'est pour contraindre les
pêcheurs à la ligne allez voter en la
question que je pose est on condamné
élection après élection à voir se
dessiner une france qui se fracture
entre les métropoles de la
mondialisation heureuse et les
territoires abandonnés tout ça sur fond
d'une abstention galopante et pour
conclure dimanche votez pour qui vous
voudrez mais dans cette période
difficile que traverse l'europe allait
voter stéphane bern est ce que vous
considérez que le débat auquel ont
assisté hier soir est encore une bonne
formule alors que la campagne
présidentielle à laquelle on assiste est
dominé par le numérique on est homo on
est haut à l'époque de tik tok de twitch
live est ce que ça marche encore ce
genre de choses là mais traverse oui je
pense je pense que pour le coup les
audiences sont encore importants donc ça
montre bien qu'il ya une forme ça fait
partie du narratif en fait du récit de
la campagne en a on attend ce moment
comme une espèce de combat de catch en
une fascination pour ça mais mais pas
uniquement pour le débat présidentiel il
y avait le débat entre zemmour et
mélenchon qui avait fait un carton
d'audience donc on aime ces moments là
parce qu'on aime la politique non ce qui
aurait invoqué cd moment de
confrontation avec le public est avec
les journalistes notamment interactivité
commandes et oui voilà c'est à une eau
est offrant stéphane bern et le débat
évidemment en fait 1,2 vision s'y
opposer entre emmanuelle coint marine le
pen et vous continuez votre tournée des
candidats ont résonné rejoignez marine
le pen dans quelques minutes et on voit
emmanuel macron en même temps stéphane
bern et rédacteur en chef et directeur
de la rédaction à paris de ouest france
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
dans un instant denis carreaux qui
dirige les rédactions du groupe nice
matin sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot merci d'être avec
nous c'est chloé mora politologue qui
est notre invité politique aujourd'hui
j'allais dire pour commenter ce débat du
deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles notre partenaire centre
france la montagne et c'est florent
buisson aujourd'hui qui est depuis
orléans journalistes à la république du
centre à une question à vous poser c'est
le troisième tour de cette
présidentielle
on écoute les moins bons jours le débat
l'a encore démontré ce sont de france
qui s'affrontent cette polarisation ne
va-t-elle pas rentrent plus délicat
l'établissement d'une majorité claire
dans les prochaines législatives de juin
ou même l'établissement d'une majorité
tout court
alors je pense que la forte de nos
institutions c'est aussi d'ailleurs leur
principal défaut c'est de parvenir coûte
que coûte à former une majorité à partir
d'une minorité dans les yeux et je vois
assez difficilement comment après une
victoire d'emmanuel maintenant ils
n'obtiendraient pas une majorité alors
peut-être pas une majorité très large
comme il a eu la dernière fois peut-être
une majorité composite avec des alliés
mais j'ai du mal à voir les français
dérogé à la règle qui s'est imposé
depuis l'instauration du quinquennat et
le fait que les législatives suivent au
fond je pense qu'il aura une majorité
mais que pour le pour autant est-ce
qu'il sera facile de gouverner nom de
hikaru chloé morin en cas de réélection
de d'emmanuel macron à quoi pourrait
ressembler cette majorité on est dans
une situation très différente de celle
de 2017 il y avait la république en
marche le modem aujourd'hui il ya
horizon il ya territoire de progrès à
quoi peut pourrait ressembler cette
future majorité déjà d'une part la
question c'est est ce qu'il va négocier
ce qui va donner une large part à ses
alliés il y avait le modem y horizon il
ya territoire de progrès que ces
terrasses qui va les accepter qu'ils
concourent sur leurs propres couleurs ou
pas à mon avis non parce que tout
simplement emmanuel macron c'est un
grand traumatisé des frondeurs du
quinquennat hollande est donc forcément
il a cette obsession depuis depuis son
premier quinquennat d'avoir une majorité
qui soit homogène et qui soit à sa main
à partir de là pour ce qui est des
oppositions on sait que généralement aux
législatives ya une très forte
mobilisation est donc nécessairement ça
sera très difficile pour les oppositions
d'obtenir une majorité comme jean luc
mélenchon le le souhaitent par exemple
alors dans l'hypothèse inverse si marine
le pen est élue la question se pose
aussi il y a cinq ans le fn avait obtenu
seulement huit sièges aux législatives
est ce à dire qu'elle va être contrainte
marine le pen de former une coalition
avec
l'équipe zemmour c'est l'objet d'une
tribune qui a été publié hier d'ailleurs
je pense que pour le coup et ce qui est
entamée entre marine le pen et eric
zemmour c'est un peu une lutte à mort
tout dépend en fait de l'altérer
politique ne primera pas c'est ce que
vous dites oui c'est à dire que si elle
souhaite remettre ça dans cinq ans se
disant ce score et est honorable je peux
gagner dans cinq ans je pense qu'elle a
intérêt à celui-ci et eric zemmour parce
que c'est une concurrence et dans ce cas
là elle n'a pas intérêt à lui laisser le
moindre espace eric zemmour tout seul il
aura jamais un seul député alors elle en
aura pas beaucoup enfin elle peut
justement elle a cette force aujourd'hui
qu'ils aient la même force que mélenchon
vis-à-vis du reste de la gauche dax
d'asphyxier la concurrence donc de ce
point de vue là je pense que ça sera
quand même difficile pour elles
d'obtenir un grand nombre de députés et
c'est un problème c'est un problème
quand on voit le poids que jean luc
mélenchon peut avoir dans les yeux le
poids que marine le pen a eu dans les
urnes se satisfaire qu'il n'est qu'une
poignée de députés ça finit par poser
problème on l'a vu avec les gilet jaune
au fond alors jean luc mélenchon
justement il est persuadé lui de pouvoir
renverser la table après le second tour
il parle d'un troisième tour il demande
aux français de les lire premier
ministre est ce que c'est une hypothèse
qui est réaliste d'une manière ou d'une
autre je pense que ça va être très
compliqué parce que même si on
additionne les scores de mélanges en
plus de ses potentiels alliés il faut
savoir qu'avec le seuil de qualification
à 12 5% des inscrits avec un taux de
participation à 50% à peu près vous
devez faire au moins 25% pour vous
qualifier donc la grande question c'est
ce qui va être capable de surmonter les
rancoeurs du passé et de sa de créer une
alliance très large à gauche alors le ps
bouge un peu puisque il a donné son
accord hier soir à des discussions est
ce que ça peut aider ça peut aider du
côté du ps parce qu'au fond le ps
aujourd'hui joue sa survie il peut il
peut ressortir du parlement sans un seul
député s'il n'a pas d'accord avec avec
le reste de la gauche mais le problème
c'est jean luc mélenchon c'est qu'on
voit bien qu'ils règlent des comptes
avec le parti socialiste et que et qui
la volonté de dialoguer avec eux n'est
pas du tout la même que celle qu'il peut
dont ils peuvent faire preuve par
exemple à l'égard des écologistes dont
on peut aussi imaginer qu'un accord avec
eux assez facilement alors à droite le
groupe des républicains disposent
aujourd'hui de 101 députés est ce que l
air peut limiter la casse après la
catastrophe du 1er tour et le score
calamiteux de de valérie pécresse
notamment grâce à son implantation
locale l'implantation l'autre et locales
valent elles pas joué et de toute façon
on va avoir enfin il ya deux phénomènes
qui vont jouer en faveur de l air pour
limiter un peu la casse
d'une part le fait que son électorat
vote alors que l'électorat de mélenchon
de de marine le pen vote - c'est quand
même des personnes plus âgées plus
éduqués ou qui ont tendance à quand même
allés aux urnes y compris pendant les
législatives et le deuxième élément qui
plaide plutôt en faveur de l air c'est
que le il y aura plus la dynamique du
vote utile au point où on l'a connu au
premier tour des présidentielles donc on
peut imaginer que certains électeurs et
l'eire qui s'était porté sur le manuel
macron en se disant bon bah il faut
faire barrage à mélenchon par exemple se
disent bon bah je vais voter pour mon
député et l'air que je connais et c'est
néanmoins avec un score tel que tel que
l'a obtenue valérie pécresse je pense
qu'il va y avoir des pertes très lourdes
alors emmanuel macron a expliqué qu'il
voulait fonder je cite un grand
mouvement politique d'unité et d'action
nicolas sarkozy de son côté appelle à un
grand rassemblement est ce que une
coalition c'est imaginable en france
puisqu'on chancelade république on
change de culture politique pour le coup
c'est la sixième
mélenchon en font oui c'est ça c'est à
dire qu'on n'est plus dans une logique
de capot la réalisation de l'assemblée
par le président de la république
ministre devient le patron c'est ce
qu'il faut c'est parce de négociation
projet par projet il ya rien dans les
institutions qui n'empêche
néanmoins on voit bien que ça n'ait
jamais et la volonté évidemment du
français l'a adoré la cohabitation au
fond les deux cohabitations vécu ils
n'ont pu y aurait donc il ya ya ya un
marqueur fort oui mais le problème c'est
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde a intérêt à réformer les
institutions de manière à ce que les
oppositions et davantage de représenter
manuel dragon sauf emmanuel macron et
c'est bien le problème est donc c'est
pour ça que françois hollande ne l'a pas
fait non plus et quand on est président
on aime bien cette espèce de surplomb et
de pouvoir très très concentré que
permettent les institutions 2040 quand
jean luc mélenchon dit élisez moi
premier ministre techniquement est ce
que c'est possible dans la mesure où
c'est le président qui désigne le
premier ministre à badens la dent les
l'hypothèse où il obtiendrait une
majorité parlementaire on aurait au
moins une crise institutionnelle si le
président refusé de nommer le voilà leur
hobby fair en mai 2000 chirac oui voilà
donc on imagine mal pour le coup avec
une assemblée majoritairement insoumise
1 emmanuel macron qui refuse de nommer
jean luc mélenchon est sarko denis carot
oui le positionnement de nicolas sarkozy
qui appelle à voter emmanuel macron mais
qui appelle aussi à cette forme de
coalition vous l'analysez comment
nicolas sarkozy je trouve qu'il a il a
perdu un peu sur tous les tableaux dans
cette affaire c'est à dire qu'il a
laissé entendre par voie de presse qui
la lisent n'allait pas soutenir sa
candidate donc il est apparu aux yeux de
sa famille politique un peu comme un
traître d'ailleurs il est sifflé ce qui
ce qui est quelque chose de première
fois deux voies là c'est la première
fois mais en même temps il n'a pas
soutenu emmanuel macron avant le premier
tour et donc ici quelque part il est au
milieu du gué et j'ai du mal à voir
comment aujourd'hui contenu durable de
la position de force dans laquelle se
trouve emmanuel macron désormais comment
est-ce qu'ils négocieraient quoi que ce
soit cloud est mort un politologue
nôtres était elle a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle la les politiques qu'on mérite
c'est on est en train d'expérimenter
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette émission
chez fayard merci denis carot la une de
nice matin évidemment les leçons du
débat avec les décryptages et le fact
checking des affirmations des deux
candidats lors du débat hier soir denis
carreaux qui dirigent des rédactions du
groupe nice matin c'est à dire également
var matin et bona combattent un merci
denis carot merci dans un instant
armelle le goff qui dirige la rédaction
de 20 minutes notre partenaire
[Musique]
bons joueurs mais le goff merci d'être
avec nous ce matin dans un instant d'une
cour intervieweront chloé morin mais
tout de suite nous partons pour
fort-de-france en martinique
et oui ou cyril boutiques et directeur
éditorial de france antilles à une
question à vous poser sur les dom-tom
version route
bonjour quand même haut rhin comment
expliquez vous que dans le débat hier
soir on est très peu parlé voir pas
parler d outre-mer alors qu'il ya quand
même un certain nombre de préoccupations
les électeurs au premier tour ont
massivement voté ici aux antilles en
guyane pour jean luc mélenchon ou se
sont abstenus avec un taux d'abstention
de plus de 60%
le fait de temps en parler dans ce débat
est-ce que de la part des deux candidats
finalistes finalement ça ne crédite pas
la thèse des électeurs chez nous que les
préoccupations des outre-mer ne sont
finalement pas forcément celle des
candidats
oui on voir un spectacle de toute façon
la manière dont les présidents de la
républiques successives gère les outre
mer c'est d'une manière assez
d'avoir deux voies oui voilà c'est on
fait un petit tour ici un petit tour là
etc mais on voit les mêmes les
déplacements sont toujours assez
folklorique même du point de vue de la
couverture ce qui est assez ce qui passe
est encadrée par le préfet et donc on a
presque l'impression que le débat était
réservé à la métropole hier soir c'était
vraiment ça et de se dire finalement
c'est un segment particulier de
l'électorat donc il faut six à
s'adresser à eux mais d'une manière
spécifique et à part en quelque sorte et
demain et demain tout à fait dans tous
les cas de figure le pays sera-t-il
gouvernable lendemain des élections et
dans le cas de figure où emmanuel macron
remporter cette élection ce qui semble
être ce que toutes les intentions de
vote semble démontrer est-ce qu'on va
assister à un retour des épisodes comme
la crise des gilet jaune qui ont qui
ceux qui sont survenus dans ce dernier
quinquennat les mêmes causes produisent
les mêmes effets si vous voulez vous
avez une concentration des pouvoirs dans
les mains de l'exécutif qui sera tout
aussi forte probablement une majorité
pour gouverner pour faire passer les
lois et donc là vous avez pris un pari
ce matin dans cette émission ça fait
deux fois que vous ai dit clairement
qu'on pense et qui aura une majorité moi
je pense qu'il y aura une majorité même
si peut-être qu'elle sera relative j'ai
du mal à imaginer une cohabitation
clairement pour une raison simple c'est
que le front des oppositions est
fracturée au moins en deux et que l'on
n'imagine pas marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon faire alliance donc à partir
de là je ne vois pas où est là comment
dire le la personnalité ou la
l'étiquette politique qui pourrait être
le réceptacle de l'ensemble des colère à
l'égard d' emmanuel macron et pour finir
de répondre à votre question ses colères
elles sont importantes puisque si l'on
cumule les voix à la fois de jean luc
mélenchon de nicolas dupont aignan
d'eric zemmour de marine le pen ça fait
déjà beaucoup beaucoup de monde mais
c'est déjà majoritaire donc c'est
mathématique ça va être un pays
difficile à gouverner est-ce que c'est
cohérent un système où on a des
candidats qui lors d'une élection
présidentielle font à 20% fin rassemble
20% des votes et qui derrière donc une
poignée de représentants dans les
assemblées oui c'est tout à fait anormal
d'ailleurs des responsables politiques
comme mon ancien patron à matignon
manuel valls qui étaient très hostiles à
l'époque à la proportionnelle plaide
désormais pour la proportionnelle je
pense que beaucoup de responsables
politiques à l'épreuve des faits se
rendre compte qu'on ne peut plus
gouverner avec une minorité contre la
majorité
or c'est ce que permettent les
institutions aujourd'hui c'est pas une
question de légitimité évidemment le
président élu aura la légitimité
des institutions
néanmoins ils ne représentent qu'une
minorité au premier tour et donc la
question de comment est ce que on prend
en compte les oppositions et comment
est-ce que leur voix est entendue est
une question qui n'est absolument pas
résolu aujourd'hui et ça permettrait de
contenir cette tripartition de la vie
politique on voit façon nommément la
scène et la tripartie sûr et je pense
que c'est un monde employés que oui oui
c'est pour le déposer le copyright non
je pense que d'autres nous on paye avant
moi mais
non pour le coup je pense qu'on
gagnerait à voir davantage de députés
france insoumise de députés est reine à
l'assemblée ne serait ce que pour voir
ce qu'ils font et pour pas être dans le
fantasme du mas si j'avais le pouvoir ce
serait merveilleux mètres dans le lac
ont paré de large peut seulement lire
pendant le débat emmanuel macron est
souvent revenu sur les votes de marine
le pen à l'assemblée démontrant à chaque
fois qu'elle avait pris des positions et
essayant d'esquisser en bilingue
principal argument la limite de cela
c'est que je pense que les français
savent que les oppositions ne peuvent
rien faire 1 l'assemblée et que au fond
ce que votre les oppositions ils peuvent
voter blanc ou noir peu importe parce
que j'ai jamais ils ne vont rien imposé
donc je pense que ça aura davantage
d'intérêt lorsqu'on saura qui peuvent
avoir un poids chloé morin armelle le
goff la jeunesse a été présente au cours
de cette campagne autant elle avait été
totalement oubliés précédente campagne
présidentielle où tant elle était très
présente et on va regarder cet extrait
marine le pen sur la sur la jeunesse
la jeunesse française a tellement
souffert tellement souffert dans les
deux dernières années deux dernières
années et demie
privé liens sociaux privés de leurs
familles bien souvent
privés de leur petit boulot donc jeté
dans la précarité
développant des problèmes psychologiques
pour certains le lourd parce qu'ils ont
très très mal vécu évidemment la crise
sanitaire que c'était une évidence pour
moi il fallait que je fasse de la
jeunesse la priorité d'un quinquennat si
les français me font cette confiance
parler aux jeunes c'est aussi parler aux
plus âgés moi c'est ce qui me frappe
c'est elle à la technique leurs parents
et nos grands parents alors par mois et
leurs grands parents qui s'inquiètent
beaucoup
et c'était déjà la technique de françois
hollande en 2012 quand il avait fait le
contrat de génération ce truc qui n'a
jamais marché mais qui que les mets que
les gens trouvent génial parce que
justement il y avait cette idée de man
va en faire c'est le lien chose pour les
jeunes or le problème de marine le pen
c'est pas tellement le vote des jeunes
c'est le vote des plus âgés donc pour
moi quand elle parle de ça évidemment
elle énonce une vérité c'est à dire
qu'elle est quand même voilà elle et
elle montre sa capacité à comprendre ce
que vit le pays
mais aussi elle parle aux plus âgés qui
est quand même un électorat beaucoup
plus compliqué pour elle mais en
revanche emmanuel macron a du mal à
s'adresser à cette jeunesse parce que la
jeunesse elle visiblement séduite par
jean luc mélenchon et par marine le pen
il ya une espèce de radicalité de la
jeunesse oui bien sûr il ya une séduit
par une forme de radicalité d'absolu je
pense que ça a toujours été le cas mais
il est vrai que emmanuel macron à un
moment donné a su séduire ces jeunes là
et que par là bas là le fait de devoir
gérer un pays on déçoit en déçoit
forcément la jeunesse ce qu'elles votent
pas elles votent non elles votent
beaucoup moins que les plus âgés et
d'ailleurs il ya des débats infinis sur
est ce qu'il est juste de laisser une
majorité de plus âgés décider de
l'avenir des plus jeunes et c'est après
ces débats philosophiques mais de fait
on a une on a eu un conflit
générationnel quasiment dans cette
élection les jeunes n'ont pas du tout
voté comme les plus âgés c'est c'est
flagrant ils ne choisissent pas le même
destin et la même vision que ce que
choisissent leurs parents leur d'entente
20 minutes oui la lune de 20 minutes
c'était donc le débat où la débâcle
c'était la une du journal
hier avec l'enjeu forcément qu'ils
étaient plus forts du côté de marine le
pen sur ce débat hier soir vous aviez
une date la petite question très vite
oui vous parlez de la force des
incarnations pour sauver les parties
c'est donc la fin des idées et est ce
que cette force des incarnations elle
peut justement entre et de la jeunesse
ah oui bien sûr moi je pense que la
jeunesse attend justement de
l'incarnation le l'exemple de jean luc
mélenchon en est la preuve éclatante
c'est avant tout sa personnalité qui
m'aidera aussi l'accord des idées aux
seniors lui dans la politique ah oui oui
mais il arrive à incarner quelque chose
qui qui qui fascine y compris les jeunes
armelle le goff directrice de la
rédaction de 20 minutes partenaires de
cette émission continue avec cauet morin
politologue et qui a écrit ce livre on a
les politiques qu'on mérite c'est ce que
nous expérimentons tout au long de cette
émission dans un instant mohamed kaci
journaliste et présentateur très connus
de cette chaîne de 64 minutes notamment
à tout de suite
[Musique]
bonjour mohamed kaci merci d'être avec
nous en serons madame morin et morale on
va parler internationale avec vous bien
et oui international et dossiers
internationaux sont venus somme toute
assez vite juste après le pouvoir
d'achat rebond en deuxième position on
n'a pas eu la vision globale de marine
le pen et emmanuel macron sur le rôle de
la france puissance nucléaire membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité
pas grand chose n'a quasiment rien sur
le sahel où la france est encore
présente exit les grands dossiers du sel
parce qu'il ya effectivement cette
guerre en ukraine en revanche l'union
européenne étaient bien présentes vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure avec
l'histoire du drapeau on va regarder
pour commencer ce premier extrait
votre projet quand on remet brique à
brique les choses en place c'est un
projet qui ne dit pas son nom mais qui
consiste à faire sortir de l'ena qui
s'appelle l'europe des nations oui enfin
si c'est que l'union européenne vous
sortez l'union européenne mme le pen nom
est pardon de vous le dire
on a même découvert le mot ripoliné
repeindre la copropriété et peser sur l
on peut dire que l'europe j'allais dire
c'est la sphère des manuels macron
sellal fait à l'aise sur ces sujets là
même il va jusqu'à demander il dit
dimanche ce sera un référendum pour ou
contre l'union européenne pour quoi
joue-t-il cette carte là leur que les
électrices et les électeurs français
sont souvent défiance vis-à-vis de
l'europe telle qu'elle fonctionne
aujourd'hui notamment les électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon je pense qu'il sait
qu'on est dans un moment où les gens ont
plutôt vu des preuves de l'utilité de
l'europe notamment dans le cadre de la
crise ukrainienne ce qui n'a pas
toujours été le cas et il ya eu des
moments où un peu vu beaucoup moins là
sur le coup vite c'était moyen mais
c'est déjà plus éloignés dans la mémoire
des gens on est quand même dans un truc
très très immédiat et c'est vrai qu'ils
aient vu des musées des périodes où
l'europe a été affligeante du point de
vue de l'ue de l'opinion française
notamment dans la crise migratoire 2015
etc mais là on est plutôt dans un moment
où les gens se disent bon c'est quand
même pas si mal d'être à l'abri des
frontières européennes et donc ils
jouent cette carte à fond et finalement
c'est assez bien joué parce
qu'aujourd'hui
c'est l'inde et la sortie potentielle de
l'union européenne même si marine le pen
ne dit plus qu'elle veut sortir de
l'euro ça reste l'un des points les plus
effrayantes du programme de marine le
pen sur l'international toujours vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure que c'est
assez révélateur du débat d'hier elle
était plus sur la défensive il était
plus offensif prenons la question de la
russie de la russie d'y construire une
europe de lisbonne à vladivostok
marine le pen lui dit vous avez cette
position vous l'avez reçu en grande
pompe vladimir poutine y compris au fort
de brégançon et lorsqu'il dit j'ai
jamais de position prix de changer de
position ne lui dit pas mais comment
allez vous faire pour vous rabibocher
avec la russie le débat s'arrête oui et
piel dit pas si ce nouvel outil c'est ça
c'est ça c'est à dire que elle elle
tient une position qui paraît inhumaine
qui consiste à dire de toute façon
faudra parler avec poutine à un moment
donné ce qui est une faute parce qu'elle
est pas obligé de le dire maintenant
voilà qu on l a condamné l'invasion
russe en ukraine de manière très claire
oui bien sûr mais elle dit quoi qu'il
arrive à un moment où on fera la bm
faudra le lien reparler mais manu est
accro parle avec vladimir poutine mâle
alpha elle ne le dit pas moi je pense
que un moment donné en réalité ils ont
une position qui n'est pas si éloigné
puisque lui continuent à avoir ce
dialogue là avec poutine alors certes il
n'a pas eu la fascination pour poutine
qui a et qu'elle a eues mais ou d'argent
ou des positions 10 hors jeu
j'ai sur la question de l'international
aussi même si je disais qu'on appelle la
vision globale emmanuel macron on a le
sentiment qu'elle essaye de la pousser
dans dans une vision recroquevillé
prenons la question du voile qui n'était
pas dans la partie internationale il lui
dit avec vous la france deviendra le
premier pays du monde à interdire ce
signe religieux dans l'espace public il
a voulu la dépeindre comme comme une
future potentielle chef de l'état
recroqueville qui couperait la france
finalement de ses voisins et du reste du
monde oui une paria moi je pense que ça
ç'a un impact assez modérée sur une
opinion française qui somme toute est
quand même très très dur sur les
questions de fond sur le rapport
d'ailleurs à l'islam en général et donc
je ne suis pas sûr que cette critique la
porte et énormément et finalement le
fait d'être
parent ya des nations et cetera je pense
que les gens vous voyez quand il lui dit
la qipao si elle réplique pas alors
qu'elle a retiré la question de la kippa
des espaces publics elle était vraiment
rentrer elle s'est empêtrée je comprends
pas pourquoi elle n'a pas à assumer
pleinement son sens qu'à la soumission
sans doute parce qu'elle craignait de
faire peur donc elle à elle a
rétropédalé oui mais ça sera discuté au
parlement etc je pense que du coup elle
a fait mais ils sont aussi et vous
clouer moi est ce que les français
perçoivent ces subtilités que nous mais
on a tiré sur national sur
l'international est ce qu'au fond tout
ça les gens qui regardent ça de chez eux
ils rentrent aussi loin et profondément
dans le dans le débat non mais c'est le
handicap d emmanuel macron c'est à dire
que les il s'adresse à des gens très
éduquée quand même quand la plupart des
démonstrations qu'il a fait honnêtement
le français moyen n'a pas les moyens de
juger de la véracité des faits et de et
de la le fast shipping palmer deep par
exemple le mans il ne lui coûtait rien
de dire mais emmanuel macron avec vous
la france les sous marins se sont
passées sous le nez on a perdu un gros
contrat ça c'est quand même les français
sont sensibles à ça quand même en disant
des émules et sur les sous-marins la
sphère australienne à oui biensur est là
elle n'a pas nécessairement pris tous
les sujets qui qui aurait fait mouche et
ça c'est assez évident qu'une seule
machine c'est oui mais le
le sujet c'est que je pense que mc
kinsey elle est gênée à partir du moment
où il ya sept jours après ces sociétés
de conseil et d analyse qui est facture
le gouvernement pour des missions
précises qui remplace l'administration
par moments le redire haut et finalement
attaqué de manière trop brutale sur
cette dépendance vis-à-vis de deux
sociétés de conseil privé s'est aussi
prêté le flanc directement à une
répartie sur la dépendance vis-à-vis de
la finance russe donc il ya des sujets
où on sent que l'un comme l'autre marché
un petit peu sur des oeufs quand même
mois m cassis merci beaucoup vous
présenter les journaux de cette chaîne
vous continuer toute la journée
j'imagine versés par des extraits du
débat un merci infiniment moins qu'avec
tout ce matin bercy flou est mort à une
question et puis surtout
une des données d'ipsos qui en disent
long quand même on va regarder ce
tableau ensemble sur l'impact de
l'élection de chaque candidat sur la
situation personnelle des gens on le
voit devant vous est derrière vous ça en
dit long marine le pen à 25 emmanuel
macron à 15 qu'est ce que veut dire
cette donnée mais ça veut dire que en
dépit du bilan d' emmanuel macron qui
lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres et pas du
tout des oignons sur les questions de
chômage par exemple on a une perception
majoritaire d'une france qui s'est
affaissée et de d'une société qui est en
voie de déclassement et de fragilisation
et que compte tenu des mesures qu'il a
mises dans son programme et notamment de
la mesure à mon avis de retraite à 65
ans il ya de manière écrasante l'idée
qu'avec macron ça c'est encore pour cent
ouais si la version se dégradera larmes
donc ce que ça peut jouer ça à lire dans
le réflexe de l'isoloir dans l'urne au
dernier moment là au tout dernier moment
explique une partie une bonne partie de
l'abstention c'est à dire que je trouve
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont sous marine le pen c'est pas
mes valeurs mais au fond franchement le
pays serait pas pire notre situation ce
qu'on va me dire ça de voter pour elle
on s'en vante pas c'est une des grandes
questions c'est à dire que par exemple
on ne sait pas si les sondeurs mesure
bien les reports de vote mélenchon sur
marine le pen parce que quand on vous
venez de la gauche c'est quand même très
difficile d'expliquer vous allez ensuite
voter marine le pen donc ça ça reste une
question on ne le saura que dimanche
mais de fait je trouve qu'elle s'est
quand même en grande partie dé
diaboliser mais que globalement cette
espèce de comment dire il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui plus tôt 10 c'est la
peste et le choléra le choléra est donc
on ne choisit pas c'est plutôt ça
l'effet que ça aujourd'hui plutôt que de
de générer un enthousiasme en faveur de
marine le pen et contre emmanuel macron
est ce ces données ipsos on sait au fond
que les français ont ce pessimisme voilà
ancré en eux mêmes ça ne révèle où on le
savait
non c'est de plus en plus marqués et 6 à
ces chiffres disent l'immense échec des
manuels macron qui est un échec comment
dire
subjectif c'est à dire qu' il n'a pas il
a réussi à inverser un certain nombre
d'indicateurs économiques mais il n'a
pas réussi à inverser les perceptions et
ça c'est beaucoup plus difficile
évidemment donc après on peut mépriser
les perceptions des gens en disant
arrêtez de vous plaindre et c'est un
autre débat mais ce qui est ce qu'il
faut c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui a été
élu pour restaurer la grandeur de la
france elle a confiance en elle de la
france et on se rend compte en fait qu'
aucune grande partie des français
considèrent d'être qu'ils sont affaiblis
avec ce président en titre et chloé
moore un politologue on a les politiques
qu'on mérite chez fayard et on a eu le
débat qu'on a mérité pour terminer ce
débrief je pense que oui et c'est à dire
un débat qui en aura on aura énervé plus
d'un ou en tout cas il n'aura pas changé
fondamentalement non plus les choses
merci et chloé morin merci mohamed kaci
on se retrouve jeudi prochain les
programmes continus les vôtres
d'ailleurs vos journaux télévisés
un instant sur tv5monde cette émission a
été réalisée avec ouest-france
nice-matin france antilles la montagne
20 minutes et je remercie thierry
barbedette et vanessa chaîne qui ont
coordonné et qu'on produit cette
émission avec nous ce matin au revoir à
tous et bonne journée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]